hey there and welcome to pro flows
number 45 i'm cameron and this one
is called blobs and let me show you why
i've got blob number one here which is
just a shape layer that's filled with
pink
as you can see here and i've got shape
layer number two
which is blob number 2 also filled with
pink
now let me show you the trick here this
is the cool part so we're going to
create a new adjustment layer
and this is just our effects layer and
we're going to go to effect and we're
going to go to blur and sharpen
fastbox blur and we're just going to
crank this up to
eight and we're gonna apply one more
effect
which is under matte and it's called
simple choker and there it is and we're
gonna set this to be the same number
as our blur radius so this is the blur
radius is eight
so let's set this to eight as well and
there we go now watch what happens i'm
gonna go ahead and lock this layer
whenever i move blob one and two close
together
they create a blob effect
and what's pretty cool about this effect
is you can increase the amount
of kind of like liquid blobbiness
between these
all you have to do is go back into your
adjustment layer and you could like
directly make this a number 30
and then make the choke mat
30 as well and it does make your blobs
smaller the higher you increase these
numbers but at the same time it creates
more of a liquid effect between these
blobs
and that's all it is it's uh it's really
fun to play around with this to animate
it
and make these liquid blobs do
blobby motion